he is considered a hero by many people
in Kosovo for his role in leading the
campaign that ended Serbian rule
but former Kosovo president Hashem
thatchi and three others are facing war
crimes charges their road to the Hague
began seven years ago when the kosovar
assembly gave the go-ahead to a special
tribunal to investigate allegations of
war crimes during the Kosovo War of the
late 1990s
under International pressure Hashem
thachi the former head of the cost of a
Liberation Army strongly backed the
court
we need to clear our names of this
unfair and unnecessary labeling of The
kosfo Liberation Army
five years later after rising to the
office of President Hashem thatchi
resigned his position and traveled to
the Hague with three others
but Veterans of the war say the
indictment is an attack on The kosova
Liberation Army
it is not individuals who are on trial
there but the kusua Liberation Army and
the freedom of the people because the
prosecutor's office refers to our
assistance as a joint criminal
Enterprise in the indictment
the indictment accuses Hashem thachi and
his three co-accused of intimidating
abusing and eliminating those they
considered enemies of the cause of a
Liberation Army
but lawyers say the prosecution may find
it difficult to prove its case
we who were in Kosovo and experienced it
all know that the soldiers and their
commanders did not have a chain of
command or control the Kosovo Liberation
Army was not a regular army in many
settlements the locals organized
themselves to defend their homes and had
nothing to do with the KLA their support
at home for the former course of a
Liberation Army leaders on trial and a
campaign to support them has been
launched
we will not affect the legal proceedings
nor do we want to but we want to provide
moral support to those who are in The
Hague tell them they're not forgotten
and that Kosovo supports them in this
challenge
the trial could last several years with
more than 300 Witnesses expected to give
evidence the accused have pleaded not
guilty Barbara engopa Al Jazeera